do you have any other Antics from your
childhood involving very dangerous
things you shouldn't have been doing
one of the my experiences are actually
kind of similar to the fire thing like I
had a couple negative experiences that
just made me stop yeah
um the firecrackers was like we kept I
built I made a firecracker with my
friend and we were super proud how did
you make a fight we opened up like all
individual caps and like packed them
into a little paper roll we made those
are really dangerous because they're
pressure sensitive so if you screw up
it'll just blow up
this is insane but we started getting
because you can't buy firecrackers in
Canada but you can buy the ones that
shoot up in the air and explode and I
realize you could just unpeel them and
take them apart but like we try to blow
you realize that no one should realize
that that's actually just a crime so is
it actually probably I don't know but I
I I I've never gone anymore I've never
had a firework in thought I should open
this up yeah see what's going on yeah no
I wanted the firecracker in it oh my but
then I started realizing like we were
they were big enough that like I think
if you held them they would literally
blow your hand off yeah well I have some
videos I can show you a test like we
bought a chicken cutlet from the from
the store and we we wrapped it yeah and
I put it on like a stand next to the
fence I want to explode it it just
sprayed like paste on the fence and I
was like yeah it's not a perfect record
we shouldn't be holding it but like your
hand would be gone yeah like you'd have
even if it doesn't blow your fingers off
you probably have like chunks of your
fingers missing and I remember just for
some reason I was like I just got scared
and I was like yeah that's cool
and then I just stopped working with
explosives like nothing actually
happened actually that's not true but so
come on so this you are the scariest I
mean this is why you're the one I do not
want to be in a prison so what we've
this is actually now that I'm thinking
it's like therapy like yeah this is okay
this is this is great this is great so
what happened was there are people
whether like this monetizes it my dad
vaguely told us about about this he's
like if you put two firecrackers in a
tube and with open ends and you link it
up properly you can launch one
firecracker out that's lit and you can
have it explode in the air okay so why
did he tell you this he said he did as a
kid
your dad is insane so we did that a
bunch yeah right and it worked but then
my dad also alluded to the fact that
he's like you could put a BB in the tube
and it's like a god
so you made a gun no but so I guess
you better go you made a projector you
made an explosive that shoots a
projectile but I'm not gonna say it
outright in a cylinder this was let's
this is many years ago for legal reasons
this was many years ago so what happened
was we did that we put one BB in it
worked really well but then I was like
if you put a lot of BBS in and you've
made
but the problem is like my dad also see
the safety thing he's like never seal
the tube because like if anything
happens it'll actually just like she
trapped a lot like so it'll be a grenade
yeah so he's like so we never sealed it
but I put all these BBS in the front
and when I lit the back of it I put too
many BBS so it kind of like sealed the
end and shot all of like the firecracker
like debris and stuff backwards yeah but
my hand was in the way oh [ __ ] so I
remember it went off and then my hand
just went numb yeah and I thought I
thought I like lost my hand but I just I
just kidding Pat I was you know kid
panic but I looked at it I remember I
just had like it just it was like
basically shotgun blasted with like
little like pieces I don't think it's
not concrete but it's like a solid thing
on each end that they make the
firecrackers out of yeah so and I just
had like a hundreds of little blood
blisters on my hand
oh my God I can't believe I'm saying
this but you like that's what's that's
what put the fear of explosives in your
head because I was like
a fear of explosives and I've never had
my hand blown off I can't believe I'm
saying this you make Michael Reeves look
well adjusted
it's crazy
the fact that you still have all your
fingers it's like America okay so so
you're you're in school at this point
right so you start high school or middle
school
in Canada yeah we don't have Middle
School in the UK yeah middle schools
around Canada but in Quebec we have uh
just high school then we have something
called sejap which is between high
school and University yeah we have
something like that okay we have
University oh okay so so you go into
high school and then presumably you're
still doing this stuff or so yeah
escalated grade seven I remember was
when I bought the blowtorch
were you okay I I have to ask you and
this is relevant to my YouTube were the
other kids scared of you
did they know what you were doing tell
people I brought the [ __ ] to school
and I kept it in my locker and I would
show it to people oh my God you were the
one quiet kid I I genuinely if you if I
if you were a kid in my school and you'd
a blowtorch I would like everyone stood
the [ __ ] away from me I actually burnt
my locker a few times at the time oh my
God okay okay so you so you buy it these
are memories that I forgot about you buy
the blowtorch and why is it such a
momentous occasion for you why is it so
special the reason it's special is
because I I don't remember exactly why I
bought the blowtorch yeah but I think
the reason why I bought it
was it was actually I used it to do my
first chemistry experiment okay I wanted
to turn I saw on YouTube a method to
take pennies and make them different
colors oh you make them like silver or
gold right right and I was just I
thought that was true YouTube sent me
down this Rabbit Hole yeah yeah so I
wanted to just make colored pennies yeah
and flex on the other kids right
okay I get that sentiment but that's
kind of hard when they think oh I want
different colored pennies they just like
paint
no but it looks it looks like the penny
is just a golden okay
I could paint it I could understand why
if if this sounded easy to do a kid
would do this to me that was like magic
because I was like this is just this
doesn't make any sense I mean I'll give
you like Street creds in school yeah
definitely able to do that and even for
me I thought it was just like magical
like paint makes sense but to like turn
it a diff like turn just have a pen
Alchemy yeah but it looks like a nickel
that's what I thought right that's just
weird okay so what happened
um long story short actually I failed
what was the experiment what do you have
to do just you just need like some drain
cleaner right and some like zinc metal
where did you get zinc metal so again I
learned it on the internet you can like
cut open batteries
I got the battery shells and then you
get the drain cleaner the problem is at
the time I use just Drano it's like
mixed with like aluminum and a bunch of
other stuff yeah I mean I tried it it
just didn't work right and I think I
tried like twice and when it failed I
kind of gave up but it was like the
first time I actually did like isn't
cutting a battery scary
she got very lucky you do this and it
didn't work all right then what what's
the next step I just gave up I guess you
didn't do any more chemistry during high
school but no I I'm trying to think and
then after that I got very I I started
getting back into fireworks the fire
came back no and I thought it's a lot
easier I wanted to make flash powder
okay what's flash powder
um it's basically what's used in
firecrackers oh is it just stuff that
lights on fire it does light on fire but
you have enough of it it just detonates
oh and I just thought it was cool is it
literally just an explosive chemicals
yeah yeah okay
so where where so yeah you failed with
the pennies but it was cool you
presumably go back to normal school life
what gets you back into this your brain
you're bringing up all this I haven't
even ever talked to us I forgot about
this the
I really wanted to make flash powder and
yeah to make it there's so I think it's
potassium perchlorate
and aluminum powder okay so like to make
the aluminum powder at the time you
couldn't just buy it so I bought like a
the way that there's so many ways people
talked about it but it's like aluminum
foil you shred it yeah and you put it
like a rock tumbler
so it was like the beginning of like
trying to do these projects for
chemistry and the potassium perchlorate
you buy like salt replacement at the
store and then you can do electrolysis
on it I think that's what you do I don't
know okay so as how old are you you did
this
15. and did you actually do electrolysis
when you're 15.
I so I don't I got sidetracked okay so I
don't think I ever made uh the flashback
the hard part I made the perchlorate but
I never made the aluminum because it was
too annoying to get the powder right so
I kind of quit I remember when they were
like when I was 16 and they were trying
to explain electrolysis to me and I was
like I don't know so this is like the
big thing about which I think going back
to what you asked about like the channel
and not really what started I did ask
about but like the mentality of it was I
didn't I never cared what electrolysis
was or how it worked it's this is how I
get what I want yeah right like it was
just a tool it's kind of like if you
have a nail and you need it to be like
hammered into something I don't care
what a hammer really is but if it works
that's what I'll use and like that's
kind of what I still do with chemistry
now right
um like I'm
I I view the like um I'm much more
interested in like what it can do for me
than like the actual process itself
right right yeah so you just want final
products you just it's not that yeah
like I'm not in innately like super
deeply fascinated but it's not about the
journey it's about the destination no it
is it is kind of both I'm trying to like
explain this because like when you go
into chemistry there's people who are
like very fascinated Yeah by like
they'll be like oh like the electrons
move like this like that's so
fascinating and I'm kind of like it is
cool but I
to me it's only cool because they move
like that and then this is the result
right so you end up learning a lot
purely out of practical yeah
implementation yeah techniques that's
interesting